je m'en excuse mais sur le plan des
idées vous l'aimez pas mes idées
ça se voit je vous condamne pas pour ça
vous gérez votre méditerranée est en
démocratie encore une fois le désaccord
n'est pas un crime
je crois que sans les français
apprécient ce genre d'émission c'est
aussi parce que j'ai eu l'occasion non
seulement de le dire mais de l'écrire
mais on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais
quand mon ami cyril hanouna invite la
porte parole des identitaires fin qui
d'autre l'invité donc donc ça veut bien
dire qu'il ya il ya d'abord un
pluralisme et je crois que le public à
la fois de tpm paix et de btp est
beaucoup plus et click mais un surcoût
plus diversifiée qu'on ne veut bien le
croire qu'on allait nous et quand vous
voyez qu'on n'ait pas à faire taire et
sigean exactement mais quand on a 30 à
40 % de gens qui votent pour des idées
comme les miennes ou proches des miennes
ça veut dire que quand vous sortez dans
la rue vous avez une chance sur trois
peut-être une chose même un peu plus de
croiser quelqu'un qui pense comme moi
qu'est ce que vous avez lu du genre vous
allez l'ostraciser et le mettre au
goulag et intellectuelle bah non vous
n'allez pas d'élections jean-gilles face
à lui ce genre est ce que vous avez été
je me suis senti à ce que vous avez été
vexé oui j'étais l'excès j'étais vexé
disons que j'ai été vexé parce que je
n'avais pas été prévenus que ça pouvait
se passer si on m'avait dit ça à la
limite j'aurais intégré ce risque et je
serais venue ou pas mais je j'aurai je
serais venu en connaissance de cause
j'ai vu quatre plein de gens qui vous
ont dit pourquoi tu m'as encore dans
l'émission de cyril hanouna après ce qui
s'est passé mais parce que j'estime que
encore une fois je pense que vous êtes
ici suffisamment intelligent je l'espère
pour pour débattre avec quelqu'un qui
n'est pas forcément d'accord avec vous
voilà ce qu'ont fait tous les douars et
donc et donc moi j'ai pas de problème
avec le débat d'idées où ça y est le
frottement de cervelle c'est quelque
chose de typiquement français et c'est
quelque chose qui doit être apprécié
nous sommes dans une démocratie ni
cervelle et la démocratie enfin comment
ce pardon par le débat d'idées voilà
alors moins ce que j'aime pas par contre
c'est qu'effectivement et j'aurais on
parle de booba c'est qu'effectivement
vous avez sur ce type de plateau si
quelqu'un est catalogué d'extrême droite
alors il va falloir ce qu'on m'explique
ce qu'est l'extrême droite
on l'a fabule de l'infamie de l'extrême
droite et tous de travers on lui rende
dans l'art en disant ah là là c'est
scandaleux veut menacer les libertés
les libertés publiques dégager d'ici
vous êtes un fasciste et herat mais par
contre lorsqu un discours de haine mais
siam sous laon et donc que lorsque
lorsque vous êtes là lorsque les mêmes
propos même des propos largement
extremis des propos haineux contre les
femmes contre les homosexuels voir
contre les minorités sont portés par des
gens issus d'une certaine diversité là
tout le monde applaudira du tout est
génial c'est pour ça que c'est pas le
cas si les paroles baluba je suis désolé
moi le cas ici samara la borne est
revenue monsieur messien vous me gênait
beaucoup là vous avez battu fait pour ça
vous avez beaucoup de défauts mais je
pensais au moins que vous étiez
courageux hors jeu mais revenons en
revanche leur choix je m'aperçois que
vous êtes lâche sur le plateau de pascal
praud
vous ne nous aimait pas on est des moins
que rien ça nous insultent ici vous
arrivez vous avez peur de nous donc non
pas du tout pourquoi c'est toi lui tous
les genres antenne vous allez leur idée
sirigu ne qui vous invite donc il est
pas beau qui me suis fait
dans les émissions lui c'est votre ami
parce que vous nous et vous venez de
dire mon ami cyril hanouna parce que
vous n'osez pas y toucher
et je vais vous expliquer que les gens
sachent qui vous est en réalité position
je vais vous expliquer ce que vous avez
fait sur les réseaux sociaux et quelles
sont vos méthodes
ouais c'est que vous avez lancé votre
chien contre moi sur les réseaux sociaux
tous les arbres évidemment j'ai eu des
milliers de messages bien sûr ça l'aide
à tenir des messages racistes et je
compte bien et ça lui laissera le
seigneur ton mais cela vous avez
télécommandé mais arrêter et n'ont
jamais fait un tweet vous avez été malin
et les gens ont commenté j'ai eu des
messages
je vous les donnerais même pas tellement
c'est indigne mais rien que pour ça rien
que pour ça ben franchement m'a donné
vous avez usé mais monsieur vous relevez
vous êtes une petite nature moi ça fait
des mois on assez de morts par rapport à
l'aller une certaine diversité encouragé
par les gens de nintendo ne dis comme ça
je vous la met sur le dos ne disent
jamais lassé de born to run amis et mes
enfants également sur le segment à
truites j'ai été contacté par la
plateforme pharos pour ça c'est la
plateforme pharos qui m'a contacté alors
arrêtez de jeunes managers sur les
réseaux sociaux il est tout